it's a privilege to join you all today
and participate in honoring your
achievements in film and perhaps deeper
and building empathy and connectedness
we share our love of film and
storytelling and therefore a deep
interest in humanity may we all also
take pride in the community we invest
our time and our passions into by
working together to build a space where
we create the world we want reflected
and understood both behind and in front
of the camera in terms of telling
everyone's story this year your films
are such a shining example of that they
are a privilege to watch and to learn
from as Einstein said creativity is
contagious
pass it on and now I am thrilled and
honored to announce each nominee and
invite you to the somewhat reckless
risers I'm not gonna like us it's not
the easiest thing I can't even read this
part because I've seen people almost
tricked so you will be gathering for the
historic class of 2017 photograph the
great news is stage managers will be
greeting you as you approach the stage
to assist you onto the risers if you
have heels you do not have to go where
they tell you to go you can just go into
the leopard park because it could be
tricky so here we go ladies and
gentlemen as I introduce each of you
aaron sorkin adapted screenplay for
Molly's game
Christie macaws go Krieger best picture
the pump
Jeff Melvin production design the shape
of water
[Applause]
Ben Morris visual effects Star Wars the
last gender the air mode el Toro Best
Picture Best directing Original
Screenplay the shape of water
voice of envoy to my cinematography
Dunkirk Andre vegan says director of
Russia's nominee for Best Foreign
Language Film Lovelace
Jason Blum Best Picture get out
[Applause]
Sarah Greenwood production design for
Beauty and the Beast
and darkest hour
[Applause]
Christopher Nolan Best Picture and
directing Dunkirk
Sam Rockwell's actor in a supporting
role three billboards outside of a
Missouri
[Applause]
Emma Thomas best picture Dunkirk
[Applause]
Steve James Best Documentary Feature
abacus small enough to jail show the
cherry visual effects war for the planet
of the eggs
[Applause]
carlos saldanha best animated feature
film Ferdinand
[Applause]
tarah Stenson original song mighty river
from mudbath Meryl Streep actress in a
leading role the post
Greta Gerwig directing an original
screenplay
[Applause]
jay-ar an onion Sparda Best Documentary
Feature faces places
[Applause]
Tatyana s regal film editing I Tanya
[Applause]
Octavia Spencer actress in a supporting
role the shape of water
[Applause]
Steven Spielberg Best Picture the post
Gary fetes production design Dunkirk
[Applause]
luca guadagnino best picture call me by
your name
[Applause]
Ramzi Naito best animated feature film
the boss baby Amy Pascal best picture
the post
[Applause]
Julianne's Slater sound editing and
sound mixing baby driver mary j blige
actress in a supporting role and
original song for mighty river from mud
bound alex' on
display original score the shape of wall
[Applause]
Jacqueline Durand costume design Beauty
and the Beast and darkest hour
Yancey Ford Best Documentary Feature
strong island
[Applause]
J miles Dale best picture the shape of
water
[Applause]
dan lemon visual-effects war for the
Planet of the Apes
[Applause]
gary oldman actor in a leading role
darkest hour
[Applause]
q welshman best animated feature film
for loving Vincent's
Paul Thomas Anderson Best Picture
[Applause]
dan Cogan Best Documentary Feature
icarus Margot Ravi actress in a leading
role
I Tanya
Lee Unkrich best animated feature film
Coco
[Applause]
Lonnie Lynn original song stand up for
something from Marshall
[Applause]
d Reese adapted screenplay mud bound
Willem Dafoe actor in a supporting role
the florida project
Allison Janney actress in a supporting
role I Sonya
Sebastiaan litleo director of Chile's
nominee for Best Foreign Language Film a
fantastic woman Rachel Morrison
cinematography
Jordan Peele
Best Picture directing an original
screenplay
get out Kristen anderson-lopez original
song remember me from Koko Robert Lopez
original song remember me from Koko
[Applause]
Ron Bartlett sound mixing blade runner'
2049
[Applause]
Michael H Weber adapted screenplay the
disaster artist
Jocelin Barnes Best Documentary Feature
strong island
[Applause]
Shawn McKittrick best picture get out
[Applause]
John Nelson visual-effects Bladerunner
2049
[Applause]
Chris Korbel visual effects Star Wars
the last Jedi
[Applause]
Pete czernin best picture three
billboards outside etting Missouri
[Applause]
glen keane best animated short film dear
basketball
[Applause]
Tom McGrath best animated feature film
the boss baby
[Applause]
Chris Overton Best live action short
film the silent child
[Applause]
Daniele Luppi Best Picture phantom
thread
[Applause]
Saoirse Ronan actress in a leading role
ladybird
jo-ann seller Best Picture phantom
thread
[Applause]
Nelson Ferrara sound editing the shape
of water
ivan McTaggart best animated feature
film loving Vincent
[Applause]
aryen tighten makeup and hairstyling
wonder
[Applause]
Kevin Wilson jr. Best live action short
film my nephew and it
[Applause]
Emily Josh best picture call me by your
name
[Applause]
Doug Hemphill sound mixing Bladerunner
2049
Lee Smith film editing Dunkirk
Katie Spencer production design Beauty
and the Beast and darkest hour
Brian Fogle Best Documentary Feature
Icarus
[Applause]
Daniel Kaluga actor in a leading role
get out
Diane Warren original song stand up for
something from Marshall
[Applause]
Dennis Gassner production design Blade
Runner 2049
[Applause]
sally hawkins actress in a leading the
shape of water
[Applause]
Luci Civic makeup and hairstyling
darkest hour
[Applause]
the Victo cat best animated short film
garden party
[Applause]
Laurie Forte best animated feature film
Ferdinand
[Applause]
Gregg land acre sound mixing Dunkirk
[Applause]
Nathan Robitaille sound editing the
shape of water
Bruno Del Bunnell cinematography darkest
hour
Julie Goldman Best Documentary Feature
abacus small enough to jail
[Applause]
Laurie Metcalf actress in a supporting
role ladybird
[Applause]
Kazuhiro Tsuji makeup and hairstyling
darkest hour
[Applause]
lissa Bruce best picture darkest hour
[Applause]
Gabrielle drop of all best animated
short film garden party
[Applause]
Theo green sound editing Blade Runner
2049
[Applause]
Daniel Philips makeup and hairstyling
Victoria and Abdul
[Applause]
Eric Felner best picture darkest hour
Paul matchless film editing baby driver
Mike Mulholland visual effects Star Wars
the last Jedi Gary a Rizzo sound mixing
Dunkirk
[Applause]
Eli Bush Best Picture Lady Bird
[Applause]
Kate Davis Best Documentary Short
subject traffic stop
[Applause]
baraz sayad Best Documentary Feature
last men in Aleppo
[Applause]
David Howell Brunner Best Documentary
Short subject traffic stop
[Applause]
Megan Ellison Best Picture phantom
thread
richard jenkins actor in a supporting
role the shape of water
[Applause]
Ren Kleiss sound editing and sound
mixing Star Wars the last Jedi
[Applause]
Timothy Shalem a actor in a leading role
call me by your name
[Applause]
Ruben Aslam director of Sweden's nominee
for Best Foreign Language Film the
square
[Applause]
Shayne view production design the shape
of water
[Applause]
dan laosan cinematography the shape of
water
Elaine macmillian Sheldon Best
Documentary Short subject heroine and
Karen Sheldon Best Documentary Short
subject heroine
[Applause]
Matthew would sound editing Star Wars
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Christian cook sound mixing the shape of
water
Dave Mullins best animated short film
Lou
Rachele Shenton Best live action short
film the silent child
Nora to me best animated feature film
the breadwinner
[Applause]
Thomas Lee right Best Documentary Short
subject Edith and Eddie
Graham Broadbent Best Picture three
billboards outside ebbing missourah
mark Mangini sound editing Blade Runner
2049
Benj passuk original song this is me
from the greatest showman
dan sudoc visual effects guardians of
the galaxy vol 2
Anthony leo best animated feature film
the breadwinner
[Applause]
David malinovski makeup and hairstyling
darkest hour
[Applause]
newest cicada costume designed the shape
of water
Christopher Townsend visual effects
guardians of the galaxy vol 2
Carter Burrell original score three
billboards outside Epping Missouri
[Applause]
Richard our Hoover visual-effects
Bladerunner 2049
Juston Paul original song this is me
from the greatest showmen
michael semana sound mixing Star Wars
the last jet
Daniel Barret visual-effects
war for the Planet of the Apes Dana
Marie best animated short film Lou
[Applause]
Douglas Urbanski best picture darkest
hour
[Applause]
Alex Gibson sound editing Dunkirk
[Applause]
max Porter best animated short film
negative space
[Applause]
Stephen Rosenbaum visual-effects Kong
Skull Island
frank stifle Best Documentary Short
subject heaven is a traffic jam on the
405
[Applause]
Stuart Wilson's sound mixing Star Wars
the last Jedi
[Applause]
Darla K Anderson Best Animated Feature
Film Coco
[Applause]
Scot bend the visual-effects Kong Skull
Island
[Applause]
rude through a hot tub best animated
short film negative space
[Applause]
mark Weingarten sound mixing Dunkirk
[Applause]
Jonathan Amos film editing baby driver
[Applause]
yawn laughs our best animated short film
revolting rhymes
[Applause]
Jeff white visual-effects Kong Skull
Island
[Applause]
mr. mark bridges costume design phantom
thread
[Applause]
David Parker sound mixing Star Wars the
lash
[Applause]
Tobias Rosen Best live action short film
what to would say all of us
[Applause]
Joel whist visual-effects
war for the Planet of the Apes
[Applause]
Scott Frank adapted screenplay Logan
[Music]
Emily be Gordon original screenplay the
big stick
Kumail Nanjiani original screenplay the
big sick
Jacob shoo best animated short film
revolting runs
[Applause]
Sydney will linskey film editing the
shape of water
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen I'm a Los Angeles
native mmm Kobe Bryant best animated
short film dear basketball that was so
fun
[Applause]
and MVP
Richard King sound editing Dunkirk
James Mangold adapted screenplay Logan
Peter Spears best picture call me by
your name
[Applause]
Thomas Lennon Best Documentary Short
subject knife skills
mark mitten Best Documentary Feature
abacus small enough to jail
Virgil Williams adapted screenplay mud
bound
[Applause]
Laura check away bets documentary Short
subject Edith and Eddie
[Applause]
Elda CO and Yeti director of Hungary's
nominee for Best Foreign Language Film
on body and soul
Scott Neustadter adapted screenplay the
disaster artist
[Music]
Raphael Saadiq original song mighty
river from mud bound
[Applause]
Brad Zorn's sound mixing the shape of
water
[Applause]
called in an austere berry production
design the shape of water
[Applause]
Josh Lawson Best live action short film
the 11 o'clock
[Applause]
Marco Marra Mito best picture call me by
your name
Shepard makeup and hair styling Victoria
and Abdul
[Applause]
Katya then hats Best live action short
film what - OH - all of us
[Applause]
the odd do airy director of Lebanon's
nominee for Best Foreign Language Film
the insults
[Applause]
Glen goats you sound mixing the shape of
water
[Applause]
Evelyn O'Neil Best Picture Lady Bird
Michael Green adapted screenplay Logan
[Applause]
mic mine artists visual effects Kong
Skull Island
Vanessa Taylor original screenplay the
shape of water
and Reid van Dyck Best live action short
film de cab Elementary
ladies and gentlemen I introduce to you
the 90th Academy Award nominees class of
2017
now
to the nominees we are about to take the
historic photo if you could please
remove your badges direct your attention
to this odd red flashing light in the
ceiling where the camera is located we
will be repeating the photograph five
times I will be counting down here we go
for the first picture three two one
guys it's just like middle school three
two one
a third photo three two one for all our
grandmas three two one and one more cuz
you're nominated for an Academy Award
three two your official nominees
certificates from the Academy will be
given to you as you depart today and
this is a reminder to all Academy
governors to meet in the international
terrorists room immediately following
the program to all of you extraordinary
artists we will be seeing you on March
4th Oscar Sunday great congratulations
and thanks from all of us for your
extraordinary work
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]